네. 안녕하세요. 어, 차타고 임장.
오늘은 그 청담동의 몰락이라고 해서
기사가 좀 나갔습니다. 뭐 맞는
부분이 있고 조금 다른 부분이
있더라고요. 그래서 한번 좀 직접
돌아보면서 다른 부분이 있는지 어
여러분들한테 좀 설명을 드리도록
하겠습니다. 거기 기사 내용 보면은
뭐 공실률이 중대형 상가가 한 23%
정도 된다 해가지고 전 분기 대비해
가지고 많이 올라갔다라는 내용이 좀
있긴 한데 일단 아셔야 될게 저희가
청담동이라고 하면은 명품거리를
많이 생각을 하잖아요. 명품 거리의
공실률이 23%다. 이거는
아니거든요. 명품 거리는 아직까지도
들여올려는 임차인들도 상당히 많은
상태입니다. 거기 내용 보면은 뭐
명동이나 아니면 뭐 한남동이나 성수
아니면 뭐 연남동 이쪽으로 이전을
했다라는 식으로 좀 돼 있는데 사실
그게 말이 안 되는게 본진은
청담동이야. 본질은 성남동이고
그쪽으로 좀 이렇게 매장을 늘린 정도
수준이고 거기에 뭐 본사가 이전했다
그런 건 아닙니다. 기사 내용에
나왔던 뭔가 여기를 다 정리하고 뭔가
그쪽으로 이동한 것처럼 돼 있는데
그거는 조금 사실과 다르다라고 보시면
될 거 같아요. 그리고 유동인고 많이
얘기를 해요. 외국인 관광객이 뭐
명동에 최근에 좀 많이 오기 시작해서
유동 인구가 이제 거기는 더 많고
여긴는 없다라는 식으로 얘기하는데
다르게 생각하셔야 되는게 명품거리는
유동 인구가 중요한게 아니라 목적성을
가지고 옵니다 사람들이이 명품을 사기
위해서 그래서 1인당 객단가가 되게
높아요. 그래서 뭐 유동 인구가 많다
적다 그게 중요한게 아니에요. 일단
여기 초입부터 좀 보자면 지금
이쪽으로 공사를 좀 상당히 많이 하고
있고 그리고 지금 우측에 보면 저
로렉스 여기 들어오는데 지금 거의
골점만 남겨 놓고 어 저렇게 만들어
놨어요. 그래서 지금 들어오려면 제가
봤을 때 한참 걸릴 것 같아요.
정확대금은 모르겠지만 엄청난 돈을
투입해 가지고 리모델링을 하려고 하는
거 같습니다. 뭐 여기 있는 건물
자체가 다 이제 세계적으로 유명한
건축가들이 설계한 건물들이고 제가
정확한 금액을 알 순 없지만 엄청난
금액을 투입해서 지금 신축을 하고
있습니다. 좌측에 보면 여기 보태가
들어오거든요. 지금 여기 보테가도
보증금만 지금 60억입니다. 예컨데
몇백억을 투입해 가지고 지금
리모델링해서 들어올 거예요. 근데
그런 명품 업체들이 만약에 명품
거리가 죽는다라고 하면 그 돈을
투입할 이유가 없거든요. 지금 이렇게
많은 돈을 투입해서 들어오는 이유가
다 있습니다. 그리고 유일하게
명품거리에 1층이 비어 있는 건물은
딱 세 개예요. 두 개는 통임대
중이고 하나가 이제 이겁니다. 업종을
되게 가려서 받고 있어요. 제가 맨날
보거든요. 비어 있는데. 근데 1층
딱 비어 있는게 지금 저 건물이
유일해요. 그리고 지금 이쪽에 보면은
티파니가 들어오거든요.이 건물 아예
부셨습니다. 통임대로 비어 있는게 두
갠데 하나가 이겁니다. 여기 건물
되게 조그만한 건데 그 저게 이제
유일하게 하나 나와 있고 중간에 그
로렉스 옆에 있는 건물이 있어요.
그래서 유일하게 이제 통임돼 나와
있는 건데 거의 지금 여기는 공실이
없다라고 보시면 돼요. 정도로이 명품
업체들이 좀 많이 들어오려고 하는 거
같고 그리고 기사 내용 중에 높은
임대료 때문에 이제 뭔가 망한 것처럼
돼 있는데 여기는 일단은 높을 수밖에
없고 그리고 세계적인 명품거리 뭐
예를 들어서 뉴욕의 뭐 5번가라든지
오모테산도라든지 막 이런데 보면은
지금 명품 거리가 임대료가 굉장히
쌉니다. 그래서 최근에 기사 나간 거
중에 명품리 임대료를 분석한 기사가
좀 있는데 면적당 금액으로 봤을 때
거의시다 10분의도 안 되는 수준의
임대료거든요. 세계적인 명품거리
대비해서는 말도 안 되게 저렴해요.
사실 청남등 명품거리가 국내에서는 뭐
비교할 만한 대상이 없고 세계적인
거리와 비교를 하자면 정말 엄청
저렴합니다. 그리고 기사에 저 건물을
놨더라고요. 근데 저 건물은 임대
들어온 걸 본 적이 없어요. 왜냐하면
저거 내부 들어가 보시면 압니다.
내부 활용도가 매우 떨어져요. 그
횡단보 하나 끼고 있지만 저기는 완전
다른 곳이에요. 지금 전체적으로
우리나라 소비 시장이 되게 죽긴
했지만 아이러니하게도 자산가들은 되게
많아졌거든요. 명품 소비층도 되게
두터워지고 이런 고급 시장 수요는
굉장히 많기 때문에이 명품 거리가 뭐
세퇴되고 망하고 뭐 여기 명품 거리가
공실률이 뭐 20몇 %고 그거는 사실
좀 내용이랑 다르다라고 볼 수
있습니다. 그리고 여기 임차인들이
오랜 기간 계약을 해요. 뭐 15년
20년 한 것도 있고 어떤 거 30년
한 것도 봤어요. 심지어 매각할 때
본인들의 허락을 좀 받아라. 우선
매수 청구권을 좀 달라. 뭐 그런
임대차계약 돼 있는 곳도 있습니다.
그 기사 내용대로 몰락되거나 그런
곳이 아니에요. 이거는 팩트입니다.
이거 반박할게 있으면 댓글 남겨
주세요. 밥만 먹고 여기만 보고
여기의 등기상 정분 증명서를 다 보고
웬만한 정보들을 다 파악을 하고
있거든요. 제가 왜 이렇게 얘기하는지
어떤게 팩트가 맞는지는 여러분들이
직접 걸어다니면서 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 찍고요. 어, 여러분들
만약에 또 궁금한 지역이 있다라고
하시면 언제든지 댓글 남겨 주시면
그쪽에 또 직접 찾아가서 촬영을
해보도록 하겠습니다. 다음 시간에
뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]